auspiciada por el auge del precio del
petróleo y del trigo por la guerra de
ucrania y por la crisis económica que
turquía viene arrastrando día desde
finales y mira desde 2021 la inflación
se están desbocando en turquía según ha
explicado esta misma mañana el instituto
oficial de estadística la cifra
interanual de inflación de este 2022
estaría por en torno al 61 por ciento
una cifra muy grande casi desbocada y
que estaría ya más por encima y sería
superior a las cifras que se llegaron
récord en turquía a finales de la década
de los noventa y principios de los 2000
que sirvieron a una crisis económica que
utilizó el actual presidente turco recep
tayyp erdogán para conseguir el poder en
ese momento era el alcalde de estambul y
no era una figura muy reconocida en todo
el país sin embargo la situación en
turquía podría ser muchísimo más grave
que lo que es ese 61% de inflación
podría marcar y es que según estudios
independientes de estadísticas está
cifra estaría la cifra real de esta
inflación sería más del doble de lo que
señala el gobierno según un estudio
independiente podría ser que la
inflación la inflación real en turquía
estuviese en torno al 140 algo que
realmente casa con lo que se vive cada
día en las calles de turquía en los
mercados donde los precios de los
alimentos también del petróleo y del
alcohol están multiplicándose a cada mes
que pasa